[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat humilié frappé
insulté parfois violées télé le
quotidien des femmes victimes de
violence qui peuvent être sexiste ou
sexuelles après la vague de
dénonciations avec les mouvements mitu
et balances ton port fin 2017
que reste-t-il du combat contre les
violences faites aux femmes
c'est le débat du jour avec nos plateaux
ce soir pour en parler sandrine grand
gambe vous êtes élu à trappes et nous
avons également florence imbert du
collectif de l'association nous tout
bonsoir à vous merci donc sur ce plateau
pour débuter ce débat un chiffre une
femme meurt tous les trois jours victime
de son conjoint ou ex conjoint
autres chiffres 225 mille femmes parents
âgés de 18 à 75 ans déclarent avoir été
victimes de violences physiques et ou
sexuelles de la part de son conjoint ou
ex conjoint
autre chiffre une femme violée toutes
les 7 minutes en france des chiffres
alarmants
comment se fait-il qu'en 2018
est-ce possible un tel constat comment
l'expliquez vous alors le sexisme
ambiant explique beaucoup de choses
c'est à dire que beaucoup d'hommes
croire et la société toute entière leur
fait croire que les femmes sont leur
propriété que les enfants sont leur
propriété
il faut préciser que les violences
sexuelles
la plupart beaucoup de victimes ont
moins de 18 ans sont des enfants et que
la probabilité la plus forte pour être
victime d'un viol c'est d'avoir déjà été
victimes de viols donc les violences
sexuelles entraîne des violences
sexuelles et on sait aussi que beaucoup
de garçons enfants subissent des
violences sexuelles qui alla due à l'âge
adulte les ainsi tous les provoque chez
eux une prise de conscience
dans le mauvais sens c'est-à-dire qu'ils
deviennent eux mêmes agresseurs sexuels
quand ils sont adultes
le fait d'avoir subi des violences soit
même quand on est enfant augmente la
probabilité d'être un agresseur quand on
est adulte et chez les filles d'être
victimes alors justement il ya eu des
actions notamment contre le harcèlement
comme les campagnes d'affichage dans les
métros vous pouvez voir à l'image
finalement après c'est vague de
dénonciations
alors il ya eu l'âge tag mis tous les
hashtags balances ton port est ce qu'on
en fait assez déjà non
même le terme dénonciation c'est mon
problème
on est sur le fait de parler on n'est
pas dans la dénonciation de parle et par
rapport à votre première question
ce qui est aussi nouveau puisqu'on est
sur des phénomènes qui existent depuis
très longtemps on est dans une société
patriarcale et donc ces phénomènes ont
existé il ya bien longtemps mais
aujourd'hui on en parle voilà ce qu'il
faut c'est inciter les femmes à parler à
créer les cadres pour qu'elle puisse
parler et donc c'est ça qu'il faut
aujourd'hui penser au-delà des
mouvements ponctuelle de de dire sur les
réseaux sociaux etc
c'est comment on accompagne les femmes
qui ont besoin de parler pour éviter
aussi les drames la prévention
et justement on assimile souvent
violences faites aux femmes avec
violence physique mais il n'y a pas
seulement ça n'oublions pas que la
violence psychologique c'est de la
violence tout court pour dénoncer cette
violence psychologique au sein du couple
des courts métrages ont été réalisés
un des plus marquants celui de 2012
réalisé par la direction de l'égalité
des chances de bruxelles et de la
fédération wallonie bruxelles
je vous propose de regarder un extrait
du court métrage qui s'appelle frais des
maris et de plongée dans le quotidien et
l'intimité de ce couple ici pas de coût
que des mots durs quand même pas mettre
sa
elle est très bien cette robe ressemble
à rien au tchad où je vais dans trouver
une moi c'est quand même pas toi qui va
choisir ma roue pour ce soir écoute tu
discutes pas tu vas faire confiance au
caire je me souviens de toi là la
première fois que je t'ai vu dans cette
soirée où je connaissais personne mais
j'étais magnifique quand je dis tu étais
magnifique ça veut dire que tu es devenu
un gros bouillon menace c'est toi ça va
fret ça va passer c'était chez gérald
ils étaient tous ces shows al omari on
n'entend plus 1 où le réseau est
interrompue
le réseau tor globules marie d'amours
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
a été déclarée grande cause du
quinquennat justement en tant qu'élu que
faites vous j'ai moi je suis élu sur un
tracteur qui a une comme une grande
cause du quinquennat nous on attend de
voir concrètement les actions et surtout
les financements c'est bien on est
cueillait des paroles mais il ya aussi
des actes après dans les communes je
crois qu'il ya plein de choses à faire
il ya des actions ponctuelles sur la
semaine qui vient dans le cadre des 25
novembre
on a des opérations dont je pourrais
vous donner le détail avec les pièces de
théâtre sensibilisation des jeunes de
sensibilisation des publics les plus
fragiles et puis il ya des actions de
long terme notamment avec le planning
familial pour accompagner les publics
tout au long de l'année parce que c'est
ça qui est aussi important ce n'est pas
d'agir tout simplement sur une journée
même si elle est allée c'est un
éclairage qui tente on a besoin mais
c'est des actions sur le long terme
alors justement en parlant d'actions
vous organisé avec le collectif avec le
collectif pardon nous tout une marche ça
se passe samedi à paris à 14h en place
de la madeleine oui à paris 250
personnalités une quinzaine de
responsables syndicaux appellent à
participer à cette marche
qu'espérez-vous avec cette marche alors
je pense qu après mythe où il ya eu
quand même une grande prise de
conscience de beaucoup de gens qui
n'étaient pas concernées dont beaucoup
d'hommes qui n'étaient pas concernés par
les violences sexuelles et sexistes qui
ne se rendait pas compte de la dimension
qu'elle avait qui ont pris conscience
qu'ils se sont aperçus que ce que
racontaient les femmes autour d'eux
n'étaient pas des exceptions que c'était
vraiment un problème de société profond
et qu'il fallait faire quelque chose
donc on se demande pourquoi les budgets
continue d'être si petit les formations
de policiers de magistrats et du
personnel éducatif et du personnel de
santé continuent d'être saupoudré sur le
territoire et non pas rendue effective
est obligatoire pour tout le monde
on se demande tout ça on se le demande
et maintenant il n'y a plus qu'une
petite portion de femmes qui se le
demandent de femmes conscientiser de
femmes qui sont engagés aux côtés des
victimes de violences depuis longtemps
il y avait une très grande partie de la
population qui se le demandent avec nous
et c'est cet espoir de faire changer les
choses de montrer au pouvoir en place
que il y a vraiment une grande partie de
la population qui est consciente de la
dimension du problème qui est consciente
que il faut que les choses changent
qu'il faut que la justice change parce
qu'on a après mitu qui n'était
effectivement pas une dénonciation
on a tout le temps entendu il faut
laisser faire la justice
les femmes ne devraient pas se faire
justice elle-même d'ailleurs elles l'ont
pas fait aucune femme n'a fait
démissionner un homme a par einstein
personne est en prison et je crois qu'il
y ait même plus et on ne l'a pas eu de
dénonciation et on dit tout le temps
forts il faut faire confiance à la
justice
or la justice ne fait pas le travail de
justice qu'elle devrait faire puisque
vous avez peut-être les chiffres 1 % des
viols qui donne des pistes en pensant
des plaintes pour viol mène à une
condamnée
il ya seulement quatre victimes sur cinq
qui dépose plainte
ça représente 10% de dépôt de plainte et
seulement 1% de condamnation du monde
politique qui est assez récente mais qui
est forte et il ya beaucoup de
personnalités syndicales politiques qui
viendront de la méditation avec benoît
hamon sera on sera présents puisque
c'est à une des thématiques qui
aujourd'hui nous semble absolument
essentiel et je pense que ça traverse
beaucoup de partis politiques
aujourd'hui et heureusement alors pour
aider ces victimes
plusieurs actions sont menées
l'association des femmes huissier de
justice de france propose cinq mille
acte d'huissier gratuit par an sur tout
le territoire français pour les femmes
victimes de violence dans le cadre
conjugal et je vous propose tout de
suite de voir ce que pensent les
yvelinois des actions menées contre les
violences faites aux femmes
ça commence petit à petit c'est très
bien il faut aller plus au delà de sa
sphère les manifestations vrai que les
lois le gouvernement pour appliquer ces
lois de plus en plus des choses tout ce
qui est à stein et ou machin machin je
suis pas forcément pour parce que ça
finit par trop centré sur certains types
de violence mais je trouve que ça sarr
porte aussi sur d'autres débats qui sont
l'avancé des femmes dans le monde
finalement il ya eu beaucoup de paroles
et pas forcément beaucoup d'action en
faudrait plutôt d'agir en dehors des
réseaux plus refuser de mouvements genre
de plus de manif autres et plus
d'affichés comme ya du vent c'était dans
les gares ou autres une marche seul
principe c'est symbolique c'est fort
cela dit je trouve aussi que des marches
on a fait un peu pour tout et n'importe
quoi en ce moment et que du coup ça a
tendance à banaliser les faits bombe que
ça peut avoir ça vient aussi de
l'éducation beaucoup je pense c'est au
niveau de l'éducation qu'il faudra agir
essentiellement parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de choses qui se passent
soit ce que dans les familles comme
violence le problème alors sa viande de
l'éducation entre autres bien sûr c'est
un axe important et je pense qu'il
faudrait que dans les programmes de
l'éducation nationale ce soit plus
largement traitée après il ya aussi il
ya des aspects culturels aussi
l'éducation c'est pas simplement
l'éducation des jeunes enfants c'est
aussi l'éducation tout au long de la vie
et dans les actions qu'on va faire à
travers notamment une représentation
d'une pièce de théâtre que la date c'est
à l'école de musique et de danse le 6
décembre et on s'appelle des coûts et du
silence et le but c'est ça c'est d'avoir
un cadre où on présente une pièce de
théâtre et après on crée le débat et où
la parole pour se libérer et essayer de
faire aussi tombe bien certains autres
stéréotypes qu'on voit aussi encore dans
les témoignages que vous avez dit filet
est-ce que c'est pas aussi un problème
de société demeure où la vo lu aulas
volonté masculine de domination de
contrôle est toujours là si je crois je
crois qu'il ya vraiment une mentalité
patriarcale de domination et de
propriété de sens de la propriété par
rapport aux femmes et aux enfants qui
est très fort et que certains hommes
questionne et déconstruisent mais
d'autres non pas du tout et plus ils ont
du pouvoir malheureusement et moins ils
sont susceptibles de déconstruire ça
donc c'est tout eu toute une structure
de pouvoir qui est nous oppresse qu'il
faut essayer d'interroger et dans l'est
c'est pour ça que les quotas par exemple
de femme politique à tous les niveaux
c'est une excellente mesure de
prévention des violences parce que avec
plus de femmes dans les structures on va
attaquer un petit peu cette hyper
masculinité au pouvoir parce que au fur
et à mesure que les femmes prennent des
postes qui ont du pouvoir et de la
surface médiatique
elles peuvent faire aussi passer des
messages différents sur ce qu'est le
pouvoir c'est à dire que le pouvoir ce
n'est pas de la domination masculine le
pouvoir c'est complètement autre chose
c'est une responsabilité
et si ce message est de plus en plus
transmis aux générations futures et même
en génération actuelle d'ailleurs on
aura progressivement un changement dans
les dynamiques
domination et des dynamiques qui sont
des dynamiques d'oppression très souvent
mais on voit qu'on en est encore loin
puisque il faut bien faire comprendre
que c'est pas une discrimination par une
d'autres c'est pas une inégalité parmi
d'autres des violences lors d'autres ces
sondes et les discriminations qui sont
qui sont à la base de notre société et
qu'il faut vraiment dénoncé en tant que
tel en tant que sujet propre ça et c'est
encore difficile de le faire accepter
dernier point avant de refermer ce débat
si des personnes victimes de violences
nous regarde quel est le conseil que
vous leur donnez alors il ya un numéro
d'urgence qui est le 39 19 qui
malheureusement repose sur une
association qui est sous-financé qui
souvent les écoutantes sont débordés
mais on peut quand même la plupart du
temps se faire aider au bout d'un moment
quand on appelle le 39 19
sinon le le plus
enfin si qui est le plus urgent c'est
d'en parler même si on n'a pas une
personne qualifiée pour en parler le
fait de l'avoir déposé dans l'oreille de
quelqu'un d'autre ça permet de marquer
une date de marquer une première un
premier témoignage qui pourra ensuite
être réveillé être ré rappelé pour
trouver le courage à un moment ou un
autre de porter plainte ou d'en parler à
un professionnel de santé
parce que le plus plus longtemps la
victime se tait et plus c'est dur de
prendre la parole donc si elle en parle
même à une personne non qualifiée tout
de suite que ce soit un parent une
parente une amie ou c'est beaucoup plus
facile ensuite vint beaucoup moins
difficile disant ensuite de pouvoir
éventuellement porter plainte ou se
rendre à l'hôpital où voilà faire une
prendre une mesure quelconque dans le
dans l'optique d'une guérison
en tout cas d'une rémission également
des associations
il forme une île forcez pas de nous on
va orienter vers des associations
pensent qu'il faut effectivement parler
donc ça soit je parlais du planning
familial tout à l'heure ce sont les
centres sociaux trouver trouver une
oreille qui ensuite sera dans les
communes orienter au mieux en fonction
aussi de type de communes et de ce qui
existe mais la première démarche c'est
celle qui est souvent la plus difficile
mais c'est celle qui va après permettre
de débloquer parfois des situations
merci à vous deux d'être venu pour ce
débat et avant de clôturer cette
émission je le rappelle un numéro à
composer si vous êtes victime de
violences le 39 19 ce numéro est gratuit
et anonyme
merci à tous d'avoir suivi ce débat on
se retrouve mercredi prochain 18 d'ici
là très belle soirée sur tv sur tv 78
[Musique]